[Music]
Jennifer Lopez gushing about her man
Alex Rodriguez on The Today Show
Wednesday morning she also dropped this
hint about her ideal marriage proposal
while recapping a major moment from the
2018 Met Gala were you there when 2
Chainz proposed to his girlfriend ah
that's anice would you ever want to be
proposed to that way like on a red card
I think I would want to be a tiny bit
more intimate about what this is amazing
I'm sure she had a Cinderella moment a
rod we hope you're taking notes cuz
that's not the only hint J Lo's been
dropping to Shabbos karaoke was
exclusively on set of Lopez's new music
video Annie oh it means the ring and it
has many speculating this is the 48 year
old singers way of telling a rod he'd
better put a ring on it of course
everyone's gonna ask you is there a ring
do you want a ring are we having a ring
I think it's more about the value of it
it's kind of like if you want me in your
life you have to give me the respect and
place in your life that I deserve okay
and there are something like I think I
mean sometimes is a symbol of that but
it's it's more of a symbolic thing yeah
I knew your bundle